说完了你手里的牌
我们说一下女生的计算规则
女生的计算规则一圈子对比
什么是圈子对比
就是任何事物的好坏
我们需要有个对比对吧
就像我在对比我自己的
手机和对比一些安卓的手机
一些几百块的手机OK
我自然知道我的手机比较好
但是我的手机没有对比的话
那其实我对这个手机
好不好的概念其实并不知道
只是觉得ok
只有这个东西能用
我才能用它
知道吗兄弟们
要有对比而女人
拿你去跟什么对比
去跟她以前经历过
的所有男人去对比
所以说兄弟们要知道
在这个女人她的阶层
她比如说是一个学生
她是一个什么
你大概知道她之前
经历过是什么样的男人
这个时候你就可以去ok
打出你自己脱颖而出的那张牌
第二个点关注点
就是所谓的有些人说过很多的Ras
很简单的一个东西
可能讲了很多期的
这里我给兄弟们讲清楚什么是Ras
你们就算知道了这个
它也不能让你变得很牛逼
这个就是一个经验累积
这个所谓的关注点
就是一个经验累积
你没有经验
你就算知道这个东西
它也没有任何卵用
所以说你需要去累积足够的经验
你累积了足够的经验
你就算知不知道这个关注点
这个东西也能自动的
让你去做出一些反应
所以这个东西它不是
一种很神奇的东西
不要他妈的被洗脑了兄弟们
比如说处女
她的关注点在于什么
在于颜值
和性张力知道吗
她不在乎你的大肌肉
她不在乎你的很有钱
她也不在乎你的很有趣
只要你长得不好看
她都不会理你
所以说处女因为她没有经历过男人
所以说她会遵从于
人类最本能的一些东西
就是颜值
还有暧昧的性张力
所以说这个时候你
一旦去展示你的金钱
展示你的社会阶级
那其实不是ok
不是很有用
我说的是那种纯处女
有一定男性经验
哪怕她接触了社会上
的男人的那种处女
那种都要好一点
但是这种纯处女
她是很难去以其他方式去搞定的
所以说你们需要注意到这个关注点
第三点真假辨别
真假辨别是什么
就是废物测试
女人她会从废物测试里面去搞清楚
你到底是真的表现出来的这么牛逼
还是假的这么牛逼
为什么
因为前面他判断出你的价值了
他肯定要去验真假对吧
就像他买了一张彩票
他必须得去刮懂不懂
如果说他觉得有价值
他才会刮
如果说没有价值
他直接会丢掉
所以说废物测试它是一件好事
因为他首先判断你有价值
他才会去验真假
这个时候你们一定要扛住知道吗
兄弟们
这就是技巧层面的一些东西了
需要多次的学习才能把
这个废物测试给过掉
所以说你一定要全身心的
投入到搭讪的这个对局里面
如果说你稍微有一点心不在焉
那么妹子就会
把你给丢掉
我们来讲一讲婊子面具
当打开多人组或者说闺蜜的时候
会出现一种东西
那就是婊子面具
它的底层逻辑是什么
就是目标更容易出现
一种选择者的框架
她会把自己默认当成一个奖品
哪怕你的潜沟通很棒
哪怕你什么都做的很好
但是只要周围有人
看到了你们之间的搭讪
这个人是她的闺蜜也好
是她的朋友也好
或者是周围的行人也好
她都有可能出现婊子面具
而且概率非常的大
所以说我给兄弟们单独把
这一个技术点拎出来讲
为什么女生会出现婊子面具
要探究这个原因
它其实是比较多的
除了你自己做的烂
我们可以改变之外
其他的东西我们都改变不了
这里给出
几个女人她自己的原因
第一是社交压力导致的
目标就是这个女生她不想
在她的身边的朋友圈里面
社交圈里面
导致自己的等级评价下降
如果说她轻易的答应你
在她的朋友面前
轻易的答应你的搭讪
那么这会让她觉得
她自己非常的廉价
所以说我们需要去处理这个问题
第二就是生活圈里面的舔狗导致的
通常是出现在一些很
认知很低的一些土妹身上
因为她们的外表
哪怕她们很土
但是她们的外表是可以睡的类型
她们的外表提高了她们的分数
但是认知匹配不上
她们脑子里还是一坨屎
所以在她们的世界里面
就觉得她的生育权
是可以控制住男人
男人他妈都是用下半身思考的废物
这也就是他们觉得
他们可以拿捏你的原因
所以说以后不要他妈
的用下半身去思考
如果说你在察觉到这个人
他的婊子面具太重了的话
你经过了你的努力也
不能改变这种现状的话
那么你可以马上收起你的意图
然后筛选掉这个女生
这样能让你的价值保持不掉的同时
还能得到能量
这就是我们要说的下一个技术点
回蓝的一个重要性
什么是回蓝
有些时候婊子面具以及太多
的拒绝会对你造成真实伤害
这也是我们单独去练习搭讪
的时候遇到的最大的问题点
你们首先要解决这个问题点
他才能让你长时间的去搭讪
而你只有长时间的去搭讪
你才能把你的所有技巧
所有行为给改变掉
这是最基础的东西兄弟们
那么怎么避免这种情况以及怎么
把这种情况的伤害降到最低呢
这就是回蓝的作用
回蓝的底层逻辑
就是自我价值认同感
以及自我行为确信感的一种表现
还需要你有极强的社交
直觉来分辨妹子的心理状态
以及她现在所处的一个心理位置
在你察觉到妹子
是一个生活很屌丝
总在幻想一些完美的事情发生对吧
他每天在幻想着中
一些几百万的彩票
当你发现他是这样一个loser
就像你一样兄弟们
像你一样loser
那么你就会对这个人下头
你从而想远离他
前提是你不要对她的逼感兴趣
前提是你不要他妈的
觉得这个人太正了
你非她不可知道吗
兄弟们不要做这种预售
当你什么时候真正的去选择女人
而不是只要是个洞就
可以插进去的时候你才能
真正的在情感里面自由
而不是被女人操控
因为你他妈知道你自己想要什么
懂吗每当你已经做的足够完美了
你已经足够努力了
你自信你又浪漫
你又风趣
你又幽默对吧
你又大方
你又很有带领性
女人还是他妈继续装她的逼
在朋友面前装她的逼
把他自己当成一个奖品
当成一个选择者
那么你就拒绝他吧
因为这是他丢失的机会
兄弟们很多低自我价值认同感的
屌丝说我这是自我安慰对吧
说我这是自慰
说我呃你自己搞不到
然后你筛选掉妹子
我在这里郑重其辞
我不是自我安慰
这他妈是一件事实
女人的生活里面充斥着各种舔狗
各种花言巧语
各种虚伪的空气
各种虚伪的泡泡
她已经受够了
她已经不想再天天
晕头转向的处理那些舔狗
处理那些傻逼
她想逃离出来
知道吧兄弟们
他在等待着一个真实且强大
的领袖带领他走出这个困境
但是他为什么不接受
因为人性往往是脆弱且懒惰的
就像你每天疯狂的刷着抖音
一遍一遍的刷
每天吃着各种垃圾食品
每天打着游戏
每天打着飞机
你知道这些东西不是一些好东西
对吧
但是你每次想要脱离他们的时候
你总会觉得你的舒适圈被打破了
你总是觉得生活索然无味
然后你又被这些奶头乐又吸进去了
我们
作为阿尔法给女人带来
的就是这样的一个东西
就是带给她正向的一些东西
她自己不选择接受
是她自己不敢去拿到这个东西
不是说她不向往
懂不懂兄弟们
脱离舒适圈是很痛苦的
但是它往往是蜕变的
这就是回蓝一个主动且
强大的一个心理实操技巧兄弟们
我们来讲一讲延续前提
什么是延续前提
在前提的后期要做出延续性
这就叫延续前提
OK这个延续性就是铺垫
邀约之类的一些事情
但是它需要夹杂着
一些假性评估来做过渡
OK什么是假性评估
我在下期会讲
但是这里我需要给到
你们一些简单的概念
让你们理解为什么要做铺垫邀约
因为你要去深入了解一个女生
你在聊天里面
你在电话里面
你不能完全了解
在搭讪里面时间太短了
所以说我们要为邀约做铺垫
做一些安排
不要等着女生他妈来安排你
不要等着女生来主动约你不可能
兄弟们 6分以上的妹子不
可能主动去邀约你
6分以下的还有可能
所以说不要去想
除非你他妈是一个超级大帅逼
或者说你是一个明星
你是一个idol
那么可能
但是那些女生都不是很优质的
我告诉你们
所以为了让她知道你
是真的想要了解她
而不是只是在乎她的奶子和屁股
那么你需要把她约出来
当面的聊
当面的搞
这样才会比较有诚意
但是如果说你直接约的话
你说我约你出来
那么他大概率会拒绝
所以说我们需要一些手段去铺垫
铺垫邀约的问题包括但不限于
这个时候我会在铺垫邀约
里面做一些假性评估的穿插
举个例子
我会说我好奇你多大
我问这个问题也不是随便乱问
兄弟们要知道
我每说一句话都是有自己的目的
特别是在跟女生
去做一些battle的时候
那么我去问她多大
这是一个什么样的行为
这是在寻找女生的对话频段搞清楚
你跟女生应该去聊什么
也就是去寻找关注点
那么在抛出这样的话之后
女生她会回什么样的一些信息
她会说她自己多大
她会说啊你多大
她会开始给你一些废测对吧
那个时候都不重要
解决掉这个东西
解决掉这个废测
或者说回答掉这个问题
你需要马上给出一个假性评估
就是给女人废测对吧
比如说我说我好奇你多大
她说一来就问年龄
这样礼貌吗
我会说哦
就一个年龄
没有什么大不了
她会说哦我23岁
这个时候我可能会说
你看起来像个少妇
这个时候就会产生情绪
知道吗兄弟们
OK但是这个东西不要去乱用
你像个少妇
这个东西不要去乱用
首先你要看她穿的很成熟
你才可以去用
如果说她穿的
她妈穿的一个洛丽塔的裙子
你说她像少妇
这很傻逼
这个时候你应该反着说OK
你23了但是你看起来像一个小学生
像一个小孩
对吧你可以反着来
我只是给兄弟们举个例
让你们好理解
不要他妈马上把我
这个话术又抱过去
疯狂的乱用
你像个少妇像个少妇
像个少妇像个少妇对吧
那就没有用
OK然后我可能会问
你是本地人吗
为什么我要去问这个兄弟们
这是为了给出一定的长期属性
同时心里确定好约会的地点
为什么我说你是本地人
吗这个东西有长期属性
兄弟们想一想
只有什么样的人才会去
问别人你是本地人吗
一定是他自己是本地人对不对
但是我没有明说我是本地人
我只是做了这样一个预设条件
懂不懂
他能导致我后面是不是
本地人我都可以随机应变
这就是你先去问这个人
是不是本地人的一个好处
然后他这个时候会说他是
本地人或者说不是本地人OK
那些都不重要
只是确定你自己跟他
以后接触的一个方向而已
问这个本地人
然后很多傻逼认为我去问
这些问题只是为了套取信息
只是为了尬聊
OK我只想说太傻了
他们的脑子可能比我
的脚的智商都要低
真的我觉得非常的搞笑
然后这个妹子她会
说她是不是本地人
她是或者不是
然后我可能都会说啊你
那边的人好像都挺黑的
你那边的人好像都喜欢吃辣的
那边的人好像都吃不得辣
那边的人好像喜欢去洗脚OK
我可能会给出那个
地方的一个阅历点
这个时候也会产生情绪
知道吗兄弟们OK
我们知道了他是什么人
他是哪里的人
他有多大了对吧
我们知道了这些信息
那么我们接下来要做什么
了解这个人的状态
就是他是在这边逛街
还是在马上要跟朋友去吃饭
接下来马上要做什么
我们需要知道这个
为什么需要知道这个
因为我们要考虑能不能及时的邀约
马上去把邀约变现
OK后面还有一些时间
或者说一些邀约的一些东西
在这里我也不赘述了
因为时间原因
所以说铺垫邀约的语境
它是什么
破除女生的婊子面具
铺垫邀约里面要夹杂假性评估
假性评估就是用来
破除女生的婊子面具
这是假性评估的作用
然后铺垫邀约的
一些信息获取
一些邀约的抛出
他是为了什么
他是为了高位框架的种植
因为是你在引导
这是其一
其二你是把这些东西给变现
知道吗兄弟们
铺垫邀约他要做非常多的东西
从而让女人知道你是去操她的
而不是去当她的好闺蜜
而不是去当他的好朋友知道吗
兄弟们这些都是用我的思维方式
所组成的一种行为模式
它不是那种垃圾自然流
让你上去打开
毫无目的的打开
那种你他妈永远学不会
我建立这些模式的初衷
不是说兄弟们让你
去学我的固定套路
我是让你去理解一个强者的思维
而我把这个思维给他们
颗粒化到你能真正马上用出来
真正用出来不会违和掉
不会成那些垃圾自然流
我是这样的一个初衷
不是让你一直的去伪装强者一直的
一直的去装成阿尔法
很多兄弟们以为我教的是邪术
但其实不是
我比他们都要正义
所以你不要搞混了
如果说你一直装下去的话
那么你始终会成为一个机器人
你会成为一个很奇怪的人
因为结果不会陪你一起演戏知道吗
兄弟们你是废物的话
终究就是废物
它不会有任何改变
所以说拿着我给你的新手套装
让自己去经历危险
经历这个游戏的一些地图去成长
当你迷茫的时候
你回来仔细体会我
文字里面的力量
与他们为什么会出现在这里的原理
你会成为一个真正的大师
那么前期的成功信号是什么
做好等级评价
同时全身心的投入对局
进入到男女框架
做好约会的准备
这就是前提阶段我们
要做到的一个目标
OK我是Jason
下期再见兄弟们